il fut un temps aux prémices du monde
[Musique]
où le soleil ne s'était jamais levé
mais même en ce temps là
une lumière rayonnait
quant au micro tout irait the way
les elfes ont des forêts à protéger
les nains gardent leurs mines
les hommes leur chante céréales mais les
pieds de l'ue n'ont pas à s'inquiéter
tant qu restants
[Musique]
on est en sécurité
vous avez assez combattu et galadriel
rangez votre épée
l'ennemi est toujours là reste à savoir
où ils se cachent
cette quête est révolue mais vous n'avez
pas vu ce que j'ai vu aujourd'hui fut
bien assez
vous n'avez pas vu
ce que moi j'ai vu
[Musique]
les ténèbres envahir la terre toute
entière
ce sera la fente pour non seulement du
pas prêter self
mais aussi de tous les peuples
[Musique]
je suis désolé mais l'heure a sonné
passé toujours avec moi
le passé est révolu
soit nous avançons
soit nous en restons prisonniers
cela pourrait être le début d'une
nouvelle ère
[Musique]
m